فقرتنا اليوم مع وضد قد تستغرب من الموضوع
ومصطلح الا انجابيه فاذا كان جديدا
بالنسبه اليك فهو ببساطه يعني رفض احضار
مواليد جدد الى الحياه
اساسا
لحتى ايضا على صفحات التواصل الاجتماعي
وتحت عناوين متعدده
ومتابعوها هم بالالف حمله شباب ضد الانجاب
مجموعه
مغاربه لا انجابيون ايضا مجموعه اخرى صفحه
ضد التناسل كذلك مجموعه اخرى يجتمع فيها
كل هؤلاء الذين يسعون لتغيير فكره الزواج
من اجل تكوين اسره الى زواج دون اطفال
بعضهم مشاهدينا يرى انجاب اطفال هو امر
غير اخلاقي واخرون يرون ان ظروف المنزليه
والمعيشيه لا تحتمل فريق ثالث ايضا يعتقد
انه كلما زاد اعداد او عدد سكان الارض
كلما قلت الموارد
سالنا الناس في مصر برايكم بسبب انتشار
فكره لا نريد انجاب الاطفال بين هذه
الفكره بين بعض الازواج الجدد من جيل
الشباب ما مرضها
[موسيقى]
ممكن يكون ما فيش لسه بيقروا بعضيهم مثلا
لو جوز صالونات ولا حاجه مش حب من بعض قوي
فبيحتاجوا وقت مثلا الناس بتقول لك هتتجوز
بعد يعني اخلف بعد سنه لان في ظل الظروف
الاقتصاديه اللي احنا عايشينها يعني يا
دوبك يكفي نفسه قدام عرف يكفي نفسه عشان
خاطر الايام ديت الظروف بقت صعبه جدا
فكل واحد بيفكر ازاي
يعني يتانى في الضغوط الحياه مش هيبقى
جايب طفل تاني
في بعض صالونات جواز مش عارفين بعض ما
عرفوش بعض كويس ده بيخلوهم ان هم ممكن
ياخدوا القرار ان هم يعني ياجلوا فكره
الانجاب افكر قبل ما اجيب عيل افكر فيه
مره واتنين وتلاته هل هو هيتظلم ولا هل
هيعيش ولا هل ايه اللي هيحصل وانا عايز
اجيب عيل يبقى احسن مني
عيشه تبقى اسوء منه
[موسيقى]
طبعا معنا الان مشاهدينا من القاهره كل من
الصحفي سليم صفي الدين والاستشاري النفسي
الدكتور علي بهنسي اهلا بكم معنا في صباح
العربيه
طبعا معنا
طبعا حضرتك
استاذ سليم
موقفك هو ضد الانجاب ونحن سنتحدث ايضا مع
الدكتور حول هذا الموضوع خليني افهم منك
استاذ سليم بدايه ليش انت وشو هو السبب
اللي بخليك تقرر انه انت ما بدك تنجب
طيب خليني اقول الانجاب بالنسبه لي هو
جريمه في حق من قررنا جلبه الى هذا العالم
المتحارب من اجل ان يعيش الصراعات
الانسانيه التي نعيشها جميعا في الوقت
الراهن
الانجاب
يعني انا علشان انجب اصلا يعني انا انا
بستغرب دايما سؤال بيوجه الي انا ومن مثلي
انت ازاي مش عايز تخلف الحقيقه ان السؤال
المناسب هو ازاي الناس عندها القدره على
انها تنجب ما هي الاسباب والدوافع
القيمه التي التي تؤدي بالناس الى الانجاب
من الاساس
وهذه سنه الحياه استاذ سليم والصراعات
والاوضاع الصعبه يعني البشريه عشرتها على
مدى فجر التاريخ لغايه الان ولو كل شخص
قال انه ما بدي اجيبه اولاد كان انقرضت
البشريه على الاقل يعني انا هون عم بكون
محامي الشيطان حتى يعني افهم منك اكثر
لماذا هل يمكن انه يكون هذا القرار يعني
غير صائب
يا سيدتي يعني حرب عالميه ولو حرب عالميه
تانيه وبشائر او تنبؤات اعتذر تنبؤات بحرب
عالميه ثالثه وحرب نوويه شامله فضلا عن
حروب العصور القديمه كل هذا لم تنتهي به
البشريه هل ستنتهي بفكره
يعتنقها مجموعه قليله جدا جدا من سكان
كوكب الارض هذا امر ليس منطقي يعني القضيه
اننا اتفضل طيب انا خليني اسال الدكتور
علي لانه الوقت ضيق وضحت هذه النقطه دكتور
علي بهنسي الاستشاري النفسي يعني واحد مش
عاوز يخلف ولكن ممكن يتجوز
تستقيم ازاي ليه
هو طبعا يعني صباح الفل على حضراتكم
دلوقتي الجزء في تكوين شخصيه الانسان او
الجزء النفسي في تكوين الانسان في جزء مهم
جدا اسمه
اللي هو الابويه شخصيه الانسان في المدرسه
التحليليه البسيطه بتعتبر في جزئين كل
الناس عندهم عندهم وده جزء مكون رئيسي في
التقسيم التحليلي النفسي لشخصيه الانسان
هل نقدر نستغني عن الجزء ده في في تكوين
هو
ليش نجلب الذنب على هذا الطفل القادم الى
الحياه
ما هو في المقابل انا علشان اتبنى هذه
الفكره لازم يكون لي سبب ليها السبب بتاع
الفكره ديت الرهبنه يستغنون عن الاطفال
لعباده هذا انقطاع لعباده وضع اخر مختلف
بالضبط بالضبط كده علشان اقدر انا كانسان
استغنى عن ان انا اكون اب او اكون مشاعر
الابوه او ما تكتملش الجزء النفسي عندي
فلازم يكون الدافع في غايه القوه
ولازم يكون
الفكره او المشاعر اللي عندي مشاعر مسيطره
علشان ما اكملش النمو النفسي مراحل الله
ايجابيه دي مرحله عاديه خالص بتحصل لكل
الناس في تطورهم النفسي ان انا في فتره
كده
بيقول لك لا انا عايز اعيش لوحده
انا انا مش معاهم ولا انا عايز اوضح
الصوره بشكل واضح تماما لكن عند اكتمال
النمو النفسي بتاعي
ولما تكون الظروف بتاعتي
اكتملت نفسيا
جايين نهدي النفوس بس يعني انا اللي سمعته
وكانه انت بتقول استاذ سليم بانه هو لسه
لم يكتمل نموه ههه العاطفي لانه هو اتخذ
مثل هذا
انا مش بقول استاذ سليم لا انا مش بشخص ان
الامور واحنا جايين نهدي النفوس طبعا اكيد
لا لا خالص انا مش بشخص ان الامور على
فكره يعني فلسفه هنلاقي انجابيه دي موجوده
من بدايه التاريخ وبنفس وبنفس الفكره
وبنفس وجهه النظر عندي سؤال هيك بسيط
وسائل الاعلام استاذ سليم استاذ
رح تندم على هذا الكلام
فبالتالي يعني توصل مرحله بتفكر بتحس انه
انا كان لازم يا ريت لو جبت اولاد ولكن
بكون فات الاوان
الانسان العاقل هو القادر على اتخاذ
القرار وتحمل طبيعياته فيما بعد انا اعتقد
اعتقد انني شخص ناضج شخص يستطيع اتخذ
قرارات قويه في حياته ويستطيع تحمل طبيعيه
هذه القرارات
المستقبل لا يعلمه احد انا انا لا اعلم في
المستقبل هل من المحتمل ان اندم ومن
المحتمل لا ولكن في النهايه ان ان ان
اصابني الندم او لم يصبني فيجب عليا تحمل
تبعيات قرارات فقط
كيف ترد على اللي يقول لك ضد الطبيعه
البشريه الطبيعه البشريه تكوين اسره خلقنا
رجل وامراه لنكون هذا الاسره وهذا السلاله
تستمر ليش تقفون ضدها لماذا
الطبيعه البشريه ايضا
يعني في مجنونها وفي مضمونها ان اكون حرا
في اتخاذ قرارات وان اتخذ قرار اصبحت عالي
يعني الاسباب كثيره جدا نحن نعيش في عالم
متحارب يحكمه مجموعه من المجرمين من جهه
وكذلك الاوضاع الاقتصاديه والعلميه
والاجتماعيه على كافه مستويات العالم وليس
على مستوى محدد لا اتكلم عن مصر ولا اتكلم
عن العالم العربي او الافريقي انما اتكلم
حتى عن المجتمع الاوروبي الامر اصبح قمه
في البشاعه الانسان يحارب من اجل ان يسيطر
على الانسان الاخر يعني كنا كنا في الاول
اتفضلي يعني وصلت
حابه ارجع للدكتور علي اساله بانه انا
عندي فرضيه او على الاقل فكره بانه
عاده النساء هم الاكثر رغبه في الانجاب من
الرجال هل ممكن نقول من واقع
ملاحظتك في مجال عملك بانه الا انجابيين
مثل الاستاذ سليم اكثر اكثرهم ذكور اكثر
من اناث ام انه يمكن هاي فرضتي خاطئه
يعني لا هو طبعا هذه الفكره
بينجذب لها الاتنين يمكن النساء اكثر
انجذابا لهذه الفكره اكثر من الرجال
وكمان هو بس الجزء المهم لازم نبقى يعني
عارفينه حاطينه في حساباتنا كلنا هو الالم
في هذه الحياه حتمي كل ما على وجه الارض
لازم يتالم لكن المعاناه هي اختيار انا
هتالم وهواجه صعوبات وهحس بالالم ده فرض
على كل المخلوقات الحيه لكن انا اختار ان
انا اعاني مع هذه الالام امم تكون الالام
دي سبب لتطور وسبب لنضج وكل التطورات
الحياتيه والدنيويه من ساعه
خلقت الحياه الى وقتنا هذا تعتمد على من
الالم هو المطور وهو النمو للشخصيتي
ولحياتي وللدنيا وللكوكب الارض كله فان
علشان
اهرب من المعاناه ان انا خلاص انهي الحياه
فانا ممكن اختار ان انا معنيش اه اختار ان
انا اتالم واواجه هذه الالام وبعد كده ده
يكون سبب في تطوري دكتور علي بهنسي على
استشاري النفسي شكرا جزيلا لك وكذلك الشكر
للصحفي سليم صفيه الدين يعني ماضيه اقلعيش
لولا فسحه الامل ان شاء الله الخير قادم
امين يا رب
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات